foreign
of ours pointed out that there is a
production of Samuel Beckett's Waiting
for Godot
that is being that has been canceled
because Beckett so this is the classic
awesome awesome freaking play
um from sort of uh theater of the Absurd
genre
and uh and
Beckett who is now dead uh required that
the characters was basically just two
characters there are a couple other
really bit players but it's uh it's a
Vladimir and estragon I want to say yeah
um
um that they beat male and
I don't know when I first heard it I was
like I guess maybe
um uh but whatever it was Beckett was
the playwright and he said it has to be
male and uh he's gone now and I think
it's his son who uh oversees his estate
and there was some
um some play being done some production
of Godot being done in which many of the
people behind the scenes many of the
people who were not on the stage were
actually female and there was no
injunction against that but they were
abiding by uh Beckett's rules that the
actors the characters are male and they
actually be played by male actors and it
was shut down because this is somehow
non-equitable right none non-equitable
not fair not not okay because we we need
to be present in everything no matter
what and you know we're not this is not
the story that we want to spend a lot of
time talking about today but
my God people
like
seriously not everyone gets to show up
in every place at every moment the idea
that
women need to be allowed to be playing
characters that were written as male
characters
in a play in which the playwright said
these are actually male characters and
they need to be played by male
characters
um is a little bit like and I will
probably take some for this but a
little bit like men who are dressed up
as women claiming that they need to be
allowed into women's music festivals or
women's domestic crisis centers or
women's sports right like nope actually
there's rules
and sometimes the rules aren't what you
like and
um you're gonna have to deal with that
yeah I mean it
invalidates the entire purpose of the
exercise right it makes which this the
the the playwright or the or the or the
the uh
desire to impose rules on any given play
that require openness to people of
configurations you know there are no
children in the play right
no one in a wheelchair in the play right
um
this is an a it's the perfect example of
sophistry yes right because the whole
point of the play is to actually say
something or in Beckett's case in a
strange way not to say something but to
explore and to explore the nature of
waiting and infinity and expectation and
hope and humanity and you know all of
these things it's not about
simultaneously a tiny play in terms of
like what happens yeah and the scope of
space that is traveled and enormous it's
like it's infinite it's in its
implications and
sorry I interrupt you but I feel like I
haven't gone back and reread it but you
know this is what I'm I love this play
yeah I have it you know I actually have
two copies of it I found it also in
another
um anthology of plays on our Shelf here
um it feels to me like it's explicitly
a non-sexual play right and so I think
that you know it's not mine to say but I
think that Godot would work if it were
all female well but I and you know okay
yes and you know there's homosexual
attraction I don't care right like I
think given that most of the world is
heterosexual and given that once you
have mixed sex groups interacting in a
very sparse place you raise this
question of like oh well what did that
mean what was that about was that was
that interest what like what is going on
there and so this like saying like no
you know what it's all male and I think
you could equally well say no it's all
female except I didn't write the play so
I don't get to say that but I think that
this would work equally well as it just
like you know what it's just going to be
all one thing so that we don't raise the
question so that issue is not Central to
the play yes but so first off
I think it is perfectly within bounds
for Becca to say this should be staged
as
males only totally I think it is
perfectly valid for somebody who wishes
to Stage the play to say I know what the
playwright's wishes were but uh it's not
his to say I'm going to Stage IT female
or I'm going to Stage it makes sex I
wouldn't I wouldn't apparently the
estate doesn't let that happen
apparently it's still somehow I don't
know the rules they're illegal there are
legal bits but at the moment that this
becomes public domain because it's
existed too long I I would not fault
anybody for violating the playwright's
wishes but I do think it ought to be you
ought to do that consciously you ought
to say here's why right here's here's
why I'm doing that and the show notes
should say you know if you have flaunted
those things legally then you need then
you should acknowledge that that's all
in the
um in the the scope I will point out
there is one section of the play that I
recall that would have to be refigured
for female characters okay if I am
remembering correctly
hope I have this correct but yeah I
probably haven't read it since high
school but yeah
um there's a point at which the futility
of waiting for Godot causes the
characters to toy with the idea of of
suicide by hanging and one of the
arguments in favor is that it will give
them erections if I remember correct I
think that does
am I wrong I I also did not go back um
but uh I think it's in there and I'm not
going to be able to find it quickly and
you know look I'm I'm uh totally open as
we I think talked about last week to
re-figuring of things like plays where
you know Romeo and Juliet is radically
refigured in West Side Story for example
yeah and so I'm up for a radical
refiguring of this and it would be
interesting to have females have that
discussion and then realize that in fact
that was not an argument in favor
because of course it wouldn't work
right you could do that so anyway
it's all it's all available for the
refiguring but nonetheless the idea that
the play is invalid because it is
inherently about males is preposterous
some things are totally Preposterous yep
[Music]